bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
sullo speciale di natale ragazzi di
dover diventa registrato il 25 di
dicembre quindi a natale quindi ragazzi
ho letteralmente sacrificato la giornata
di natale la mia giornata di natale per
farmi questo regalo a voi ci tenevo
veramente tantissimo a fargli un regalo
che fosse diverso da tutto il resto a
farvi sorridere a regalarmi almeno un
sorriso per quanto io possa farlo quindi
ragazzi vi basta anche veramente
soltanto un mi piace al video per farmi
capire che non è stato tempo sprecato e
che abbiate apprezzato comunque il gesto
ragazzi per me vuol dire veramente
tantissimo questo natale ragazzi ho
deciso di farvi una vera e propria
sorpresa ha deciso per questo natale di
fare uno speciale veicolare mi sarei
travestito da babbo natale utilizzando
questa bellissima giacca che mi rende
molto sexy questo cappello fantastico e
questa barba finta per trasformarmi in
letteralmente in babbo natale in modo
tale da non farmi riconoscere il suo
amico da voi e poi tirarmi giù la barba
di botto per vedere tutte le vostre
azioni ragazzi sarà epico ve lo assicuro
eviti ragazzi direi che possiamo
cominciare trasformation
insomma
che la festa abbia inizio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie
dio
ciao
[Musica]
prima
chi può avere
mi
[Musica]
no grazie
si no
cosa buona ora voglio per natale a
playstation 4
tante donne e tanti tanti cambio tappeto
ma senti a se io metto le donne nel suo
conto
guarda che me le tengo io e non è che
puoi prendere donne tutte quante
lei che cerchi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
voi proprio voi non potete passare buon
natale comunque
[Musica]
grazie
no
facciamo una cosa che aspetta di
richiamo più tardi
[Musica]
tranquillo che babbo fahmy importatante
siringhe
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie
[Musica]
per dio
come stai i passi un po di trucco che vi
serve
[Musica]
ma chiesto gran figo qui i ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto perché mi
sono divertito veramente tantissimo a
farlo credo che sia stata una delle
emozioni più grandi che abbia mai
provato in vita mia quindi ragazzi se il
video vi è piaciuto condividetelo su
facebook se volete oppure lasciando mi
piace qui sotto insomma non vi costa
nulla comunque fate quello che volete
l'importante è che possiate un felice
natale delle felici vacanze perché ve lo
auguro di cuore a tutti quanti dei
ragazzi starò fuori casa fino al 6 di
gennaio come vi avevo già detto quindi
non potrà registrare fino ad allora ma
comunque su facebook vi faccio sapere
che sono vivo state tranquilli e quindi
ragazzi come al solito se vi do è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche al pagine di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
sente la crisi discrete legni ci
rivediamo il prossimo video dei ragazzi